as you may or may not know i am a star
wars fan and there is no way that i am
not going to sit here and ask you a
question about kenobi but i know you got
to be careful with your answers i'll
just say
were you a star wars fan going in like
was this one of these things where they
called you about kenobi you're like are
you effing kidding me
yeah i'm uh
i was watching star wars before i came
down here right now
i'm a real big star wars fan and um you
know i
i had auditioned for
uh uh lando for the solo film and when i
didn't get it it like crushed me i was
like you know what i quit i'm going back
to being a writer like i'm done
and you know i was filming swagger and
my agents were like yo
um
we need you free in the next two days
noon
all right all right like just listen you
want to take this meeting so i took it
and it was deb lord deb shout out to
lord deb debra child and um yeah she
gave me an opportunity of a lifetime and
it's uh god
i can't wait to talk about it so fast
i want to talk about it so bad but i
know mickey probably still has my phone
bugged
and i you know i just love my family
[Laughter]
uh i really really cannot wait to talk
to you about it
can you tease were you able to touch and
use a lightsaber are you allowed to say
it
all i'm going to say is
i really am a fan of you and mcgregor
that's my boy and my man camille camille
is my dog that's my he was um he's
camille's really been a major motivation
for me when it comes to getting in shape
for dinner thieves too
because of just how jacked he got
uh for eternals and uh yeah he he's got
his his line open for me any questions
that i need
and uh yeah he's got an action figure
now because he's in the eternals and you
know i'm gonna need that he said he'll
give me
uh you know a good price for it so we'll
see how that goes i got news for you
when you're in star wars most likely
you'll also be an action figure
this is something i think you can talk
about though um
they use this really cool technology the
volume when you're making star wars and
i wanted to know what was your reaction
working with the volume technology what
impressed you what was cool about it
what's so crazy about the volume is like
you really forget like after a while you
forget
that you're just in this studio well you
know and
honestly the scariest part about it is
when they turn it off
because you'll be sitting somewhere some
cave in the middle of whatever
you got background on the volume working
around and it just you get so engulfed
in in the scene that when they turn it
off and the entire room you're in just
goes white yeah it's it's kind of like a
matrix moment when they were when he
visits the architect it was it was a
a crazy experience and
it really would have saved a lot of
people back in the day to have that type
of technology i could just imagine you
know filming on location and these
no disrespect but these terrible places
so like you know it definitely saved a
lot of a lot of man hours
um it's it's
it's hard to explain the feeling that it
gives you walking in there the the the
abilities that
it brings as filmmakers what it just
gives us so much that normally you'd
have to be
playing pretend on a green screen or
just you know okay this looks like this
and and getting terrible descriptions
and yeah it's a it's a time saver it's a
lifesaver
and uh
god
somebody please give me more star wars
jobs